merci Pierre-Antoine Lévy de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure élite du Tarn-et-Garonne
monte du groupe Union centriste on va
parler de votre texte qui vise à aider
les étudiants à ce restaurer à des
tarifs peu chers on en parle dans
quelques instants c'est au Sénat cet
après-midi d'abord évidemment
l'actualité c'est la réforme des
retraites et ses consultations
d'Elisabeth borne ce matin à Matignon
elle reçoit les syndicats est-ce que
vous pensez qu'elle va réussir à briser
la glace avec la CFDT comme lui a
demandé Hervé Marseille votre président
de groupe ça me paraît compliqué parce
que aujourd'hui on l'a vu dans la
présentation venez de faire pour pouvoir
discuter il faut être déjà d'accord sur
un principe c'est de pas demander d'un
côté le retrait de la réforme de l'autre
côté du côté du gouvernement de dire
qu'il n'y aura pas de négociation sur
l'âge de départ donc déjà on est dans
une posture qui est compliqué
bon c'est consultations et sont
nécessaires mes oreilles d’être fait
avant parce que elles ont lieu après la
réforme des retraites à mon avis pour
préparer la future loi travail et voir
comment justement le dialogue peut être
restauré avec les syndicats puisque
c'est de ce dialogue dont on parle
aujourd'hui et de communication puisque
cette réforme de retraite qui a été
faite elle a été très mal expliquée et
surtout on a très mal communiqué dessus
pour vous c'est un problème de pédagogie
ou c'est un problème de méthode les deux
problèmes de méthodes puisque des
généralement avant de commencer une
réforme on essaie de discuter on essaie
de se mettre autour de la table on
attend aussi le bon moment vous savez il
y a des bons et des mauvais moments on
est quand même dans une crise assez
compliquée crise d'inflation crise
énergétique une guerre en Ukraine les
Français sont inquiets français ont peur
ont peur de savoir comment se chauffer
comment manger et c'était peut-être pas
le bon moment donc problème de
calendrier problème de méthode aussi la
loi travail va arriver après
la fin de l'été pourvu il aurait fallu
la faire arriver avant d'abord s'occuper
du travail des salariés et ensuite
sachant que
cette réforme elle est nécessaire et
indispensable chiffre d'affaires et il
faut la faire selon une bonne méthode
avec une vraie discussion et je pense
que la discussion qui a lieu aujourd'hui
alors on verra je vais pas je vais
attendre de voir qu'est-ce qu'il en sort
mais enfin on a déjà vu les premiers
commentaires des responsables politiques
ça laisse présager rien de très positif
mais en fait attendre
elisabethorn doit rester inflexible avec
les syndicats ou est-ce qu'il faut il
faut qu'elle fasse un pas vers eux
est-ce qu'il faut qu'elle fasse des
concessions je pense qu'il faut déjà
essayer de trouver une porte de
négociation une piste de négociation il
est pas acceptable d'un côté que les
syndicats disent nous on vient si vous
retirez votre réformes et de l'autre
côté est compliqué pour les syndicats
d'entendre dire vous venez mais il y a
des choses sur lesquelles on ne
discutera pas faut mettre sur la table
discuter et ensuite attendre les jours
qui viennent puisque il y a aussi une
décision importante qui aura lieu le 14
avril c'est la la réponse du Conseil
constitutionnelle sur la validité ou pas
de la réforme ou de certains points de
la porte de la sortie de crise la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel vous
savez on va attendre déjà de ce que va
dire le Conseil j'écoutais avec
attention les commentaires de plusieurs
constitutionnalistes c'est assez
intéressant il y en a qui disent que le
texte doit être censuré d'autres qui
disent qu'il n'a absolument rien à
attendre de censure et que le texte est
conforme c'est comme des médecins vous
savez sur des diagnostics qui sont un
peu différents donc on va tendre vous
savez le conseil c'est le Conseil des
Sages il est là pour donner son avis
avis qui n'est pas contestable qui
s'applique à tous attendons son verdict
et nous verrons la semaine prochaine
demain il y a une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation la onzième on a vu que la
mobilisation a été moindre lors de la
dixième journée mais quand même elle
reste à un niveau qui est très élevé
est-ce que vous redoutez ce que ce
mouvement peut devenir le redoute
toujours redoute également les
mouvements de violence vous savez les
manifestations ont commencé dans le
calme ont commencé un petit peu
paisiblement c'est à dire que les gens
venaient montrer leur opposition mais
dans un esprit plutôt apaisé depuis
quelques semaines c'est pas du tout la
même ambiance on voit qu'il y a quand
même
au milieu des manifestants vous avez des
mouvements très violents qui sont
attisés par le tragoche qui sont là pour
casser qui sont là pour blesser qui sont
là pour en plus casser le mouvement de
manifestations et surtout donner une
mauvaise image de la manifestation donc
je suis inquiet bien sûr comme beaucoup
j'observe avec beaucoup de crainte et
beaucoup d'attention ce qui se passe
c'est ce qui va se passer demain mais il
faut être très vigilant parce que ces
mouvements peuvent vraiment dégénérer il
y a Gérard Darmanin sera additionné et
auditionné aujourd'hui au Parlement sur
sa gestion du maintien de l'ordre
qu'attendez-vous de cette audition mais
tout simplement qu'on puisse avoir une
vraie version de ce qui s'est passé
c'est aujourd'hui je trouve assez
regrettable de taper sur les forces de
l'ordre de dire que c'est eux qui sont
responsables vous savez moi je salue
leur courage leur courage c'est un
courage assez important parce que on a
eu assez de souligne on le voit dans les
manifestations je le disais qu'il y a
quelques secondes il y a des
manifestants qui sont là pour s'opposer
et faire entendre leur voix de manière
paisible et l'autre qui sont là pour
casser pour tuer et pour tuer de la
police pour tuer du policier
quand même autre chose que du policier
d'autres il faut absolument que Gérald
Darmanin dise ce qui s'est passé il y a
beaucoup de fake news qui circulait
notamment à scène souligne en disant que
le SAMU avait été empêché de venir bon
il a été prouvé que c'était faux donc on
veut la vérité il y a des enquêtes qui
ont été lancées par les procure de la
République par le préfet de police de
Paris et par et donc par Gérald Darmanin
lui-même on veut la vérité et on veut
que le ministre puisse expliquer
paisiblement devant le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale sur ce qui s'est
réellement passé il y a aussi des
blocages des occupations de fac avec
parfois des dégradations comment vous
analysez ce malaise étudiant beaucoup de
provocations et beaucoup de
manipulations c'est encore une fois
les blocages on peut manifester on peut
s'opposer les étudiants le droit mais on
peut pas bloquer le blocage d'une
université n'est pas n'est pas autorisé
on peut par contre critiquer encore une
fois cette minorité qui empêche la
majorité des étudiants de venir
travailler parce que on entend beaucoup
la voix de bloc bien entendu des
étudiants qui se plaignent de voir leur
partiel arriver sans pour avoir de cours
sont inquiets de voir s'ils vont pouvoir
valider leur année d'études et donc
encore une fois c'est une minorité vous
savez on entend
200-300 étudiants sur des universités de
10 10 15000 personnes donc 7 minorités
faut qu'elle fasse attention parce
qu'elle est souvent manipulée elle est
souvent violente donc il faut encore une
fois faire attention vous avez l'exemple
de Bordeaux la victoire l'Université de
Bordeaux qui a été débloqué la semaine
dernière mais à quel prix un million
d'euros de dégâts 6 mois de travaux pour
réhabiliter une université au patrimoine
classique dévastée c'est absolument
scandaleux le président de l'université
aurait pu faire appel à la force
publique bien avant on voit qu'avec un
résultat aujourd'hui que l'on voit on va
continuer à parler des étudiants mais
sous un automne puisque vous souhaitez
lutter contre les inégalités
territoriales en accès en matière
d'accès à une restauration à un tarif
modéré pour les étudiants le texte que
vous avez déposé c'est examiné
aujourd'hui en seconde lecture au Sénat
on va voir les détails de ce texte avec
Steve Jourdain
[Musique]
examine donc la proposition de votre
Pierre-Antoine Lévy pour lutter contre
la précarité étudiante leur est grave on
va voir ces images Oriane ces images
c'était la semaine dernière place des
Invalides à Paris à quelques pas de
l'Assemblée nationale des centaines
d'étudiants qui font la queue pour
recevoir les colis d'aide alimentaire
l'opération est organisée par un
syndicat étudiant qui constate que
depuis la crise sanitaire le phénomène
se tarit pas il est aussi
identique partout sur le territoire
écoutez
la réalité c'est qu'en fait la précarité
étudiante n'a jamais disparu elle n'est
pas disparue avec le covid elle a
continué à la continuer à s'aggraver
même avec des distributions qu'on a
organisées où il y avait plus de 1000
étudiants quand même qui faisaient là
que et donc et même dans des petites
villes où on a des chiffres aussi assez
conséquents ce qui montre bien
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un réel problème
un chiffre et un exemple très concret
pour mesurer l'ampleur de la précarité
des étudiants l'université Bordeaux
Montaigne a réalisé une étude et publier
un rapport il y a deux semaines là-bas
90% des étudiants vivent avec un budget
inférieur au seuil de pauvreté un
étudiant sur deux un étudiant sur deux
vies avec moi de 400 euros par mois tout
ça évidemment dans un contexte de très
forte inflation et votre texte
Pierre-Antoine Lévy a pour but initial
de mettre en place un ticket resto
étudiant oui il a proposition loi parle
d'un constat beaucoup d'étudiants n'ont
pas accès au système de restauration
universitaire la raison est simple
certains endroits en sont dépourvus en
France certains lieux d'études situés
notamment dans des communes rurales ou
dans des petites villes ne propose pas
d'offre à destination de leurs étudiants
qui sont contraints quand ils le peuvent
de se replier sur la restauration rapide
le dispositif proposé par votre
proposition de loi est simple il s'agit
de créer un ticket restaurant étudiant à
l'image de ce qui se fait par exemple
dans les entreprises avec les tickets
resto pour les salariés tous les
étudiants qui n'ont pas accès à une
structure de restauration universitaire
pourront en bénéficier au total entre
200 000 et 500 000 étudiants pourraient
être concernés par le dispositif
dispositif qui a été validé par
l'Assemblée nationale le texte arrive
donc aujourd'hui en deuxième lecture au
Sénat il a été un peu modifié par les
députés qui en ont en quelque sorte
élargi les modalités il s'agit
maintenant plus généralement de verser
une aide financière aux étudiants qui
n'ont pas accès à la restauration
universitaire une aide qui permettra de
couvrir les bons d'achat ou les cartes
alimentaires est-ce que la rédaction des
députés vous convient
alors vous avez raison de le dire le
l'objectif initial de ma proposition de
loi était de créer un ticket restaurant
étudiant ce qui était une solution
beaucoup plus facile et pratique à
mettre en place pour tous les étudiants
qui n'étaient pas concernés et qui
n'avait pas accès à une offre de
restauration universitaire vous savez on
a parlé de ces fameuses zone blanche ces
hommes blanches sont des villes moyennes
des villes de montagne ou des villes des
villes de taille plutôt moyenne qui qui
ont des universités des antennes des
extensions d'université mais qui n'ont
pas de restauration universitaire et
donc l'objectif c'était de donner un
ticket restaurant à ses étudiants basés
sur le même système que le ticket resto
classique participation de l'employeur
au ticket resto une valeur faciale de 7
6 7 euros en cas d'espèce sur les
étudiants 6,60 puisque le coût d'un
repas universitaire c'est 3,30 € pour un
étudiant non boursier et le fameux repas
1 euro qui a été mis en place et pour
l'instant maintenu pour les étudiants
boursiers
et donc effectivement ce dispositif
avait été voté au Sénat en première
lecture en juin 2021 il a été modifié en
octobre 2021 à l'Assemblée nationale et
le ticket restaurant a disparu le nom
n'est plus le ticket restaurant c'est
offre de restauration à tarif modéré
c'est un dispositif qui gagne le mérite
au moins de mettre l'accent sur la
précarité étudiante on a vu dans votre
portage encore une fois des files
d'attente qui continuent malgré la fin
de la covid la crise sanitaire elle a
été amplifiée par cette crise sanitaire
cette précarité étudiante et dans ces
dispositif alors qu'il a été adopté par
l'Assemblée qui sera peut-être comment
combien d'étudiants sont concernés alors
on a on a évalué entre 200 et 500 000
étudiants le nombre d'étudiants pourront
être concernés par cette cette mesure
alors
il y a pas de conditions de ressources
alors il y a des conditions de
ressources pour les étudiants boursiers
pour l'instant encore une fois ça sera
une discussion que nous aurons avec la
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
surtout une fois que la loi sera
promulguée parce que on va promulguer la
loi en tout cas on va la beauté conforme
à l'Assemblée nationale il faut que
j'explique rapidement pourquoi cette loi
n'est pas tout à fait celle que j'avais
voulu au départ mais elle arrive en
deuxième lecture au Sénat et si nous la
votons conforme elle peut s'appliquer le
président de la République peut la
promulguer et les décrets d'applications
peuvent être pris par la ministre
justement pour définir le cadre
d'application de cette proposition de
loi donc si nous changeons une seule
virgule on espère qu'elle sera effective
à la rentrée prochaine c'est le but en
tout cas de la beauté au mois d'avril
dans le cadre de la niche parlementaire
du groupe centriste donc l'objectif
c'est de permettre au CROUS puisque les
maîtres d'oeuvre ce sont les CROUS qui
devront
conventionner avec structures publiques
ou privées qui existent peut-être déjà
dans les villes moyennes et permettre à
ces étudiants d'avoir accès à une
restauration à tarif modéré donc
l'objectif c'est d'avoir le même de les
mêmes droits pour ces étudiants que les
étudiants qui ont accès une restauration
dans un centre universitaire plus
important les grands sont les grandes
métropoles où ils peuvent s'alimenter
midi et soir 1 euro pour les boursiers
et à 3 euros 30 pour les nombreux
inégalités territoriales en matière
d'accès à la restauration pour les
étudiants quand vous avez on vous fait
un repas 1 euro et que vous n'avez pas
de points de restauration universitaire
ça vous sert à quoi vous faites comment
pour manger
le deuxième volet de cette proposition
de loi c'est de permettre quand il n'y
aura pas de possibilité de
conventionnement mais de donner une aide
financière correspondant à au prix en
tout cas encore une fois au prix du
repas soit 1 € soit toujours ou 30 à
l'étudiant qui pour perdre lui permettre
de s'acheter à manger parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'étudiant qui n'a pas
accès à une restauration universitaire
parce qu'il n'y a pas de site il y a pas
de restaurant comment fait-il il y a des
inégalités l'objectif c'est de
proposition de loi c'est d'aller essayer
de réduire ses inégalités sur les
gouvernement et sur la même ligne que
vous et que les députés que de
l'Assemblée nationale à ce niveau
d'application va intervenir dans les
ministres
on va écouter attentive attentivement ça
déclaration j'ai l'impression quand même
que le gouvernement a changé en tout cas
dans sa doctrine vous avez entendu la
semaine dernière la ministre Retailleau
qui a annoncé une revalorisation assez
importante des bourses
et donc on a la volonté aujourd'hui je
pense que le gouvernement a compris
cette situation on l'a un petit peu aidé
également vous savez ça fait quand même
trois ans qu'avec Laurent Lafont avec
Jean Grey qui rapporte du texte on
travaille sur cette précarité étudiante
vous aviez la mission étudiante présidée
par Pierre ouzulias qui a mis également
l'accent sur les problématiques pas que
de restauration de logement de santé
mentale également donc qui ont été
exacerbés par cette crise de la covid-19
voilà le gouvernement a changé de
position c'est aussi il y a un contexte
évidemment social particulier mais
également qui est beaucoup plus
importante aussi un contexte politique
un peu particulier avec ces jeunes qui
arrivent dans les mobilisations est-ce
que vous voyez un moyen aussi peut-être
de calmer la colère des jeunes je pense
qu'il faut les entendre encore une fois
les jeunes
manifestent leur détresse on l'a vu dans
les manifestations la vue dans les
universités et il faut entendre cette
détresse ces reportages ce reportage que
vous avez vu nous en avons vu des
tailles d'État pendant la crise
sanitaire c'est inacceptable au 21ème
siècle de voir que les étudiants peuvent
pas s'alimenter leur objectif c'est de
faire leurs études nous devons les
mettre dans les meilleures conditions
pour réussir leurs études voilà
un revenu universel étudiant ça pourrait
être une bonne idée certains économistes
le proposent alors c'est une ça peut
être une solution encore une fois et ça
qu'il finance comment le finance-t-on
faut pas que ça se fasse au détriment de
tout le reste de tous les mécanismes de
la chaîne de construction de on va dire
des logements construction de
restauration universitaire
quid sur les éligibilité parce que c'est
un revenu universel qui dit revenu
universel c'est dit que tout le monde
peut y avoir droit aux étudiants vous
dites pas non je dis que c'est à étudier
RSA jeune 18-24 ans a étudié à étudier
mais encore une fois il y a pas mal
d'école à on va dire à relancer le RSA
est financé par les départements les
départements sont en difficulté
financièrement est-ce que c'est l'État
qui va financer est-ce que c'est les
départements tout ce travail il faut le
faire mais il faut pas que ça soit au
détriment de tout le reste de toute la
politique de développement de la vie
étudiante
merci à tout à l'heure on parlera de la
nupes exactement
on va dire ça comme ça tout à l'heure ce
sera dans le classeur
on va parler de la fin de vie Pierre
Antoine Lévy puisque la convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie a donc rendu
ses conclusions les citoyens sont
favorables à une évolution de la loi
classique et favorable à la mise en
place d'une aide active à mourir vous
aussi c'est un sujet très délicat vous
savez je crois que c'est une situation
personnelle
un vécu familial qui peut inciter à être
pour ou contre cette cette le suicide
assisté ou l'euthanasie puisque c'est de
ça dont il s'agit vous savez type
personnel moi j'étais interrogé j'ai
reçu des associations j'ai pas encore
fait ma conviction vous savez je suis
difficile de dire qu'on va aider
quelqu'un à mourir qu'on va prendre
cette décision je crois qu'il faut
attendre de voir qu'est-ce qui va être
mis dans la loi pour pouvoir se faire
une idée et peut-être avoir une
connexion un peu plus affirmée ce que je
lis également dans le rapport de la
convention citoyenne des 184 citoyens
qui ont donné leur avis outre le fait
qu'ils sont recommandent le Suisse
assister et l'euthanasie ils disent
aussi quand même que la loi clé si
nonity n'est pas suffisamment appliquée
il y a quand même 21 départements où il
n'y a pas de soins palliatifs mis en
place il faut mettre les moyens il faut
déjà que la loi soit appliquée sur tout
le territoire donc cette loi clé
islonetti ce qui me concerne je
considère qu'elle va déjà loin mais il
faut qu'elle soit applicable partout ce
qui est pas le cas aujourd'hui c'est de
faire en sorte que cette loi soit
appliquée plutôt que de changer la loi
et d'en faire une nouvelle
en tout cas il faut déjà que la loi
klice Leonetti qui est une bonne noix je
pense honnêtement qui a été complété en
2015 2014 2015 soit appliqué sur le
territoire et après la discussion
palliatifs après sur la fin de vie je
crois que c'est voilà il faut attendre
les discussions faut attendre le texte
de l'eau en ce qui contient et peut-être
se faire sa propre opinion personnelle
moi quand je discute avec mes collègues
sénateurs de tout bord politique
certains sont pour parce qu'ils ont été
confrontés à une situation personnelle
difficile à un accompagnement moi même
j'ai j'ai été confronté à
l'accompagnement de mes grands-parents
de mon père je pouvais pas me résoudre à
cette situation de de dire ben voilà je
vais appuyer sur le bouton donc c'est
pas possible il y a aujourd'hui des
dispositifs qui existent sur la chaîne
vie peut-être faut-il aller plus loin
encore une fois faut qu'il y ait une
vraie discussion et peut-être un
cheminement personnel pour permettre
d'aller de voter la loi et dans la loi
classique la directive anticipée c'est à
dire que le patient peut exprimer sa pas
suffisamment connu elle est plus connue
elle est peu appliquée est-ce qu'il faut
travailler là-dessus il faut travailler
dessus parce que vous avez déjà
effectivement cette disposition de la
directive anticipée qui est pas si
connue qui est passé connu donc la loi
vous avez une loi qui a mon avis est une
bonne loi franchement mais encore une
fois c'est une boule loi n'est bonne que
si elle est connue si elle est appliquée
et surtout si elle est diffusée donc
essayons également de faire un peu de
pédagogie sur cette loi lundi en
recevant les conclusions de la
convention citoyenne et Emmanuel Macron
est resté assez flou sur son avis
personnel sur la question il renvoie au
Parlement il promet une loi d'ici la fin
de l'été il a eu raison le chef de
l'État de ne pas te donner de direction
pour vous complètement encore une fois
cette
convention citoyenne elle mérite de
donner des pistes mais c'est au
Parlement de voter encore une fois on
est dans une assemblée l'Assemblée
nationale va donner son choix le Sénat
donnera son vote mais le président de la
République je vous disais à son intime
conviction personnelle certainement il
veut peut-être pas la donner pour
laisser le débat s'instaurer entre les
députés entre les sénateurs
attendons de voir ce que la loi comporte
et nous chacun nous avancerons sur ce
sujet mais c'est bien de pouvoir en
discuter allez pour terminer on va voir
l'actualité dans votre Sud-Ouest on va à
Bordeaux retrouver Xavier sauta
journaliste à sud-ouest bonjour Xavier
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous Xavier
avec vous on parle de la ligne à grande
vitesse entre Bordeaux et Toulouse et la
question était au cœur d'un colloque sur
la mobilité organisée il y a quelques
jours absolument
LGV c'est une vieille histoire ça fait
quand même quelques décennies qu'on en
parle oui effectivement Sud-Ouest a bah
voilà organisé un coloc autour d'une
question assez simple au fond avec ses
objectifs de neutralité carbone comment
quel impact auront-ils en fait sur les
déplacements au quotidien alors il y a
une foule de sujets qui ont été évoqués
évidemment la route la route est-elle
devenue tabou dans ce monde dans une
région je vous la rappelle où la ville
phare a été prise par un écologiste il y
a un vrai sujet et toutes ces questions
de ferroviaire et notamment de LGV alors
Clément bonne n'a pas pu venir puisque
les ministres étaient privés de sortie
l'année au moins participé il a donné
quelques garanties sur la tenue du
calendrier ça va intéresser le sénateur
Lévy la tenue du calendrier sur cet LGV
en fait il y a un double projet on part
de Bordeaux on part sur Toulouse horizon
2030 calendrier a priori tenu et l'autre
petit barreau qui pose un vrai problème
dans notre région en tout cas en
nouvelle-aquitaine c'est Bordeaux Dax et
la liaison avec l'Espagne ou l'Espagne
a-t-on beaucoup de la France puisque eux
seront à la frontière dès 2028 et en
face et bien pas grand chose pour le
moment
Xavier vous avez une question j'imagine
pour Pierre-Antoine Levy
précisément c'est sur ces questions de
ferroviaire on le disait ce projet de
LGV est allé pas vieux comme Hérode mais
enfin ça fait ça fait quand même
quelques années qu'on en parle 14
milliards d'euros ce projet GPSO grand
projet du Sud-Ouest donc pour relier
Bordeaux - Toulouse et Bordeaux Dax 14
milliards d'euros en face c'est un
besoin de train au quotidien la question
elle est simple est-ce qu'on peut faire
du en même temps en terme de ferroviaire
est-ce que la France a les moyens de
faire et de la LGV et des trains du
quotidien
alors vous avez une question vraiment
une très bonne question que vous posez
d'abord c'est très ancien et je peux
dire on était beaucoup plus jeune quand
on a commencé à parler de LGV vous savez
le grand débat de 2005 il y a 20 ans
disait que effectivement Toulouse était
la seule grande métropole qui n'était
pas couvert par la ligne à grande
vitesse il faut aujourd'hui 4h30 au plus
rapide pour faire Toulouse Paris en TGV
puisque pour faire aujourd'hui Toulouse
Bordeaux il faut deux heures à peu près
2h15 et 2h11 pour faire Bordeaux Paris
donc 4h20 85 qu'est ce qui est très long
quand on voit que d'autres liaisons
entre Marseille et Paris c'est 3 heures
donc il est acceptable aujourd'hui que
Toulouse soit aussi loin mais encore une
fois 14 milliards c'était 8 9 milliards
il y a 10 ans moi quand je suis arrivé à
la mairie de Montauban nous avons
travaillé sur ce sujet aux côtés de
Brigitte barré sur la LGB le tracé était
déjà connu en 2008-2009 on savait qu'il
y aurait une gare LGB à Montauban
ensuite pour des Bizzbee politique pour
des changements de le changement de cap
également il y a une présidentielle une
présidence de la République qui a
totalement arrêté le projet mais on a
perdu 10 ans et aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'on reprend on reprend un calendrier
en expliquant qu'effectivement il faut
cette liaison Toulouse Bordeaux et il
faut mettre les moyens parce que il est
encore une fois si on veut réellement
que la LGV arrive et surtout Toulouse la
métropole toulousaine soit accessible
mais il faut mettre les moyens sur
le calendrier ben j'ai vu lundi il y a
deux jours le préfet de région
Pierre-André Durand qui nous a confirmé
que le calendrier serait tenu donc
démarrage des travaux 2024 et objectif
du premier train 2032 donc c'est un
petit peu plus loin que les 2030 dont
vous parlez mais c'est 2032 on va
s'accrocher assez cette horizon j'avoue
que ces gens Castex l'an dernier qui a
débloqué la situation et qui était très
impliqué
est-ce que là depuis qu'il est parti de
Matignon l'implication est la même
alors les présidents de président de
région sont très impliqués le maire de
Toulouse est également impliqué
président du Grand montaubanais le
président du Département aujourd'hui il
y a une vraie volonté politique et
surtout une association politique
complète qui veut que cette LGB se met
en place maintenant il faut y mettre les
moyens et surtout montrer qu'on est prêt
en commençant les travaux et si je crois
que quand on aura commencé ses travaux
qu'on verra que ben voilà on verra qu'on
a vraiment un prix le prix la mesure de
ce chantier et qu'on que les peut-être
que les Tarn-et-Garonne et les
ogaronnais et tous ceux qui sont des
servi par cette gare mais verront que
l'État est prêt que les collectivités
sont prêts à faire que la LGV arrive en
Haute-Garonne et en Tarn-et-Garonne
d'ici 2032 merci Xavier Sota et merci
pour votre très bonne question Xavier
merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec une de Sud-Ouest ce matin Bordeaux
veut garder cette trottinette c'est elle
a une de votre journal merci Xavier Sota
merci Pierre-Antoine Navy d'avoir été
avec nous on suivra l'examen de votre
texte cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat et dans 20 minutes dans le club
des territoires on va parler des
consultations d'Elizabeth borne à
Matignon ça continue toute la journée